what's up wolfgang today's video is
going to be on venom I had a few friends
ask me where exactly venom came from
because all they've seen is spider-man 3
and not much more in the comics there is
a lot to venom including many different
hosts and many different storylines that
it goes down so in this video I'm going
to try to keep it fairly simple and
really just talk about what I think is
relevant to the new venom movie coming
out in October if you're new to my
channel we are currently doing a
giveaway if you'd like to enter our
giveaway for your chance to win a
speaker system all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel subscribe to the
stupidest waves channel leave a like and
drop a comment below with your favorite
superhero that could be from Marvel DC
or anything else so to start off the
venom suit is actually an alien species
known as symbiotes the symbiotes home
planet is actually in the same galaxy
that Earth is in and is called Clint are
many people believe that the venom
species the symbiotes are actually these
super evil horrible creatures and that's
actually not how they started they
started off as a race that really just
wanted to help people and they do this
through bonding with people but the
problem is that if they bond with the
wrong person and there's some sort of
imbalance then the symbiote becomes
corrupt and evil and the issue here is
that when the bond between the symbiote
and the host is not perfect
then the symbiote eventually ends up
killing the host due to draining it of
adrenaline and energy and this began to
happen until eventually almost every
symbiote was corrupt and evil and then
there was the Venom symbiote who was
actually viewed as crazy by the other
symbiotes because it was still a
peaceful symbiote and it still wanted a
mutual bond with the toast
rather than dominating it so the other
symbiotes thinking it was crazy actually
threw it in a prison and that's when its
first human host found it can you guess
who it is
many believe that it is spider-man but
it is actually Deadpool that's right
Deadpool was the first human to
everywhere at the Venom symbiote but
once he puts it on he quickly realizes
that it's alive and interfering with his
mind he takes it off right before
spider-man shows up and then spider-man
himself puts it on and takes it to earth
after being bonded with the suit for
sometime he would eventually learn that
it was alive and controlling his body at
night and with the help of mr. fantastic
and the Human Torch learned that it was
actually week against sound they were
able to get rid of it using sonic blast
but the suit eventually found its way
back to Peter Parker spider-man
eventually ends up at the bell tower of
the Our Lady of Saints Church and rings
the bell to get the symbiote off this is
a scene that you probably remember from
spider-man 3 the Venom symbiote actually
is really hurt that spider-man rejected
it and from here it starts this really
weird love-hate relationship with
spider-man where it wants the bomb
within one moment and then the next
wants to kill him
the symbiote eventually found its way
back to Deadpool and after Deadpool
rejected it again found its way to Eddie
Brock Eddie Brock is the main character
that would be played by Tom Hardy in the
new movie venom coming out in October
Eddie Brock was also the character
Topher Grace played in spider-man 3 and
with the exception of spider-man Eddie
Brock is the most common and famous host
that the Venom symbiote bonds with in
the comics and in spider-man 3 Eddie
Brock was a reporter for The Daily Globe
but was fired after spider-man debunk
some of his fake stories that he
released it's not an easy road from
Eddie from this point on he finds out
that he has adrenal cancer his father
disowned him and he gets divorced by his
wife during all of this Eddie
contemplates suicide and eventually
makes his way to the Our Lady of Saints
Church to pray for forgiveness and yes
that is the same Church where Peter
Parker gets rid of the Venom symbiote in
the bell tower this is where the Venom
symbiote it finds Eddie Brock Eddie at
this point hates spider-man spider-man
basically cost him everything and the
Venom symbiote is drawn to Eddie's
infatuation with spider-man this fueled
even more so now the Venom symbiote
desire to bond with spider-man again or
to kill him now having seen the new
trailer for the new venom movie coming
out this isn't the story that they're
gonna go with in the movie it seems like
he still has a job as a reporter and it
seems like he still has a wife but it
does seem like they are sticking to some
of the storyline of dr. Carlton Drake
dr. Carlton Drake is the CEO of the Life
Foundation and runs illegal experiments
on humans and the comics he tries to
make children of venom and is successful
he creates five new symbiotes and if you
look on IMDB you can see the character
name
Donna Diego or otherwise known as scream
who is one of the five new symbiotes
that dr. Carlton Drake makes so it looks
like we might have the battle between
venom and scream in the new venom movie
this would be really cool I think it
would be really awesome to see this and
I'm really excited to see the storyline
that they go with in the new venom movie
coming out so that is it for the brief
history of venom I hope you all enjoyed
it if you did please hit that thumbs up
button also be sure to subscribe to my
channel to join the wolf gang and stay
up to date on venom marvel at all things
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof wolf what the hell are you
[Music]
our feet